when we think of the richest families in
the world we think of people like the
walton family and the saudi royal family
and though they do have enormous amounts
of wealth they're not exactly 100 family
businesses today walmart is a public
company and half of the company is owned
by investors meanwhile the saudi royal
family is more of a dictatorship than a
family business there is 100 billion
conglomerate though that is still almost
completely owned by the founding family
and that is of course the infamous koch
brothers today the two rich's co-cures
themselves are worth
122.6 billion dollars so here's how the
koch brothers ended up owning the
world's richest private family business
it all started on september 23rd 1900
when fred chase coke was born in quanah
texas fred's father harry koch was a
dutch immigrant who originally worked as
a princess apprentice back in the
netherlands harry had immigrated to the
us with the american dream and he bought
the tribune chief newspaper after he
arrived in america
this provided the family with a decent
living but nothing too crazy fred would
end up attending rice university in 1917
where he spent two years before
transferring to mit
fred finished up his chemical
engineering degree at mit in 1922 and
instantly jumped into the workforce fred
scored a job at texaco probably as a
chemical engineer he jumped round from
job to job working up the corporate
ladder with each switch within a few
years fred has secured a job as chief
engineer at the medway oil and storage
company though this was likely a super
nice gig fred wasn't quite satisfied he
wanted to follow in his father's
footsteps and start his own company so
in 1925 he reached out to a classmate
from mit named keith winkler who had
started his own company called keith
winkler engineering company he
eventually quit the business and the
company would be left to fred
being an extremely small player within
the oil industry fred had to think of
some creative solutions to efficiently
compete against the big players fred's
first step in this direction was
developing a more efficient thermal
cracking process which allowed small
refineries to turn crude oil into
gasoline
larger oil companies quickly caught
sight of this invention and decided to
crush fred with litigation they launched
44 lawsuits against fred which of course
drowned him for many years
given that most of his lawsuits were
utter bs designed to simply push out
fred from the business fred ended up
winning basically every single lawsuit
fred won 43 out of the 44 lawsuits filed
against him and it was eventually
discovered that the lawsuit he lost was
due to a bribe judge so really he won
every single one of them
nonetheless as fred dealt with the
litigation it was extremely difficult
for him to conduct business in the us
so he took his invention to the soviet
union at first fred was extremely
cautious when it came to the soviets as
he was worried that they wouldn't pay
him so fred demanded that he be paid up
front and the soviets agreed in 1929
fred started working with soviet
officials to set up 15 oil refineries he
also trained bolshevik engineers to
operate and run these refineries for
many years it seemed like the
partnership was progressing phenomenally
fred had earned about five hundred
thousand dollars but once the soviets
got a hang of things they decided to cut
out fred stalin started taking out coke
employees which quickly pushed fred out
of the soviet union regretting the
collaboration altogether
back at home fred was still handling the
onslaught of lawsuits so he looked for
other international opportunities and he
would land on germany germany was being
led by some crazy people with crazy
beliefs but there was no denying that
the country was progressing rapidly so
fred took the opportunity fred ended up
building a massive refinery in hamburg
which was personally approved by hitler
himself the koch family has since tried
to cover up this part of his story for
obvious reasons
but the high frequency of fred's visits
to germany suggests that germany was
indeed a major part of his business
during the 1930s fun fact rumors suggest
that fred almost boarded the hindenburg
during one of his trips to germany but a
scheduling delay saved him from the
accident
by the end of the 1930s fred finished up
with his commitments to germany and
things were looking better than ever
before fred had become quite wealthy
from his business in the soviet union
and germany and he was able to form
international connections in the
meantime the 44 lawsuits were finally
winding down after 15 years and these
turned out to be a good thing as well as
fred ended up winning 1.5 million
through the lawsuits ironically that's
three times the amount he was paid by
stalin with all this money connections
and experience fred was finally able to
turn his attention onto the american
market in 1941 with the founding of koch
engineering company the next 20 years
were pretty much smooth sailing for fred
having worked with stalin and hitler and
having defended himself from the oil
giants actually growing an oil company
in america wasn't that difficult for
fred he made a plethora of partnerships
acquisitions and deals and soon enough
fred became a multi-deca millionaire
businessman by the 1960s and this is
when he would face his last major
challenge which was figuring out what to
do with his business after his death
fred had four sons and was hoping that
as they grew up they would develop an
interest in the family business but this
wasn't the case while his children did
care about preserving the family world
none of his children really cared about
running the business itself this was
especially true with his oldest son fred
koch jr fred jr attended harvard but he
got a humanities degree which was not
very applicable to the family business
moreover fred jr joined the us navy
after graduation so fred jr wasn't
really a choice as a result fred ended
up choosing his most educated son
charles charles had also attended mit
like fred and he had a bachelor's in
general engineering and a dual masters
in nuclear and chemical engineering
despite being well qualified to run the
business charles also wasn't interested
in taking over the family business it
wasn't until fred made an ultimatum that
he was going to sell their company if
charles didn't take over that charles
joined the company charles joined the
company in 1961 and it was pretty good
timing as fred passed away just six
years later in 1967 due to a heart
attack charles would of course become
the new ceo and chairman of the company
a couple of years later charles brother
david would also join the company as a
technical services manager david also
had a bachelor's and a master's in
chemical engineering from mit so he fit
right in david would eventually end up
opening a new office in new york and to
become the president of one of the
company's divisions
at this point charles had done most of
the heavy lifting when it came to
actually running and growing the
business after his father's death and
david was the second most involved bill
didn't join the company until 1974 but
he would serve the pot quite heavily
bill had also gone to mit and not only
did he have a bachelor's and master's
but also a doctoral degree in chemical
engineering
so you would think that he would fit
right in but this wasn't the case
according to charles bill wanted higher
level positions but the divisions that
bill ran were usually not as profitable
so it didn't make sense to promote him
up the corporate ladder
bill also had a massive problem with how
charles was spending the company's money
charles was and still is a super
capitalist and despises socialist ideas
his father had gotten screwed over by
stalin so charles felt that nothing good
could come out of socialistic programs
like social security minimum wage
requirements and welfare charles had
been spending large amounts of money
funding libertarian presidential
candidates who upheld these beliefs bill
hated this and these tensions would blow
over in christmas of 1979 when bill
ignited a flame at the family
get-together bill suggested that just
because charles had grown the company
doesn't mean that the other brothers
don't have a right to decide the future
of the company
at this point their mother was still
alive and she was technically the one
who owned the company
so bill asked her mother how she was
going to split up the company their
mother started crying that it had come
down to this and left the dinner table
and this was the last christmas the
cokes spent together bill went ahead and
got some other board members on his side
along with her other brother fred jr
ironically the two brothers who had done
the lease for the company were trying to
take over the company bill organized a
coup to fire charles and take over but
fortunately for charles he would have
just barely enough votes to keep him in
power though bill's coup had failed it
was clear how big of a threat he was so
charles decided to give bill what he
wanted and move on both bill and charles
called in a bunch of financial
institutions like morgan stanley and
goldman sachs the value coke industries
on june 4th 1983 charles ranged for a
buyout of bill and fred jr's takes in
the business bill was given 470 million
dollars and fred jr was given 330
million dollars charles hoped that this
would finally bring peace to cook
industries but the piece was short-lived
just a few years later bill started to
complain that he was underpaid for a
stake in the business and started filing
a bunch of lawsuits against koch
industries bill pursued these lawsuits
up until the late 1990s and he did get a
little bit more money but eventually
bill did give in
bill walked away with a great amount of
money but he destroyed his relationship
with charles and david and just sticking
around would have resulted in way more
money but this is the path bill chose
in the meantime charles owned 42 percent
of the company and david owned another
42 percent the final 16 was owned by one
of their father's friends howard
marshall ii today koch industries has
roughly 100 000 employees and posing 115
billion revenue annually to put that
into perspective that's 30 billion
dollars more than facebook so it's not
surprising that both david and charles
fortunes are each worth 62 billion
dollars
unfortunately david died about two years
ago due to prostate cancer and his
wealth is now managed by his wife julia
charles on the other hand is still alive
at 85 years old and he is still the ceo
and chairman of cook industries and
that's the story of the world's richest
family business do you guys think bill's
fight was justified comment that down
below
also drop a like if you think fred
senior was a boss and of course consider
joining our discord community to suggest
future video ideas and consider
subscribing to see more questions
logically answered but until then i'm
hari and i'll see you guys on the next
one